hi folks ron joyner field agronomist
with pioneer here in central texas as
you can see behind me it's planting time
i'm going to go over a few key things
you want to watch out for when it's
planting time and some of the things
that will make you successful one of the
most important things that you want to
be careful of is as you move from field
to field or start planning that you're
monitoring your planter dip just because
you set it one time doesn't always
mean that it's going to be correct as
field conditions change from one field
to the next
one of the things i like to use you can
see here are these handy
pioneer measuring tools you move the
dirt back away from the sides there
notice there's a seed down in the trench
right here
take one lay it across and put the other
one there that's about two and a quarter
inches great job by this particular
griller so one thing i like to do
besides just checking planting depth is
look at the number of seeds uh in a row
and what kind of spacing we're getting
in more than one spot so for example
here you know we're about 8.7
you know approximately close to 9 there
so 8.7 to 9 inches i also like to keep
with me this time of year if i'm running
a planter i put this in the tractor
he's on 30 inch rows if you go across
and you look at
about 8.7 inches between the seeds on 30
inch rows that's about 24 000 which is a
great population for a dry land area
one other key thing to make note of this
time of year is what is your soil
temperature what's that temperature
doing i stuck this thermometer in the
ground it's early in the morning right
now and we're at about 60 degrees we
always like to be at a minimum of about
50 with a warming trend occurring so if
you look at the weather forecast and
it's calling for
isolated showers or cooler weather you
might want to consider delaying planting
for a day or two to make sure that
you're giving the seed every chance it
can to emerge and do the best that it
can
so again
make sure your seed spacing is correct
check your planter depth not just at the
first field you start on but every time
you move fields and occasionally at
random times during the planting season
be sure that your soil temperature is a
minimum of 50 degrees for corn and
climbing with a warming trend watch out
for cold weather and showers hope you
have a happy planting season again ron
from pioneer thanks for your business
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights